WELL, TIME FOR THE FRIEND
ZONE.
WE BRING A FRIEND OF FOX ON
THE SHOW.
DAN IS ONE OF THE BEST FRIENDS
AT FOX.
ONE OF THE PEOPLE WHO HELPS
THE PLACE RUN.
HE APPEARS ON "YOUR WORLD"
WITH NEIL CAVUTO AND HAS A
NOVEL CALLED "BLOOD IN THE
STREETS."
IT'S SO IMPRESSIVE.
THE OBVIOUS QUESTION, WHEN DID
YOU WRITE THIS?
>> WELL, JEEZ, I WROTE THIS
BACK, IT STARTED AS A SCREEN
PLAY AND I WROTE IT YEARS AGO.
2003.
TO MAYBE 2006.
THEN I ENDED UP TURNING IT
INTO A NOVEL IN 2012.
THAT WAS AROUND THE TIME YOU
READ IT.
YOU KNOW, YOU WERE SO GREAT TO
LOOK IT OVER AND ALL OF THAT.
IT TOOK A COUPLE OF YEARS TO
REFINING IT BEFORE I WAS ABLE
TO GET IT OUT THERE MARKET SO
TO SPEAK.
>> Tucker: WHY DID YOU WRITE
A SCREEN PLAY AND THEN A
NOVEL?
>> I WANTED TO MAKE AT IT
MOVIE.
THE BOOK IN THIS CONTEXT NOW
IS CINEMATIC.
I WENT TO FILM SCHOOL AND MY
ORIGINAL IDEA WAS TO MAKE A
MAUVE WE HAVE AND WRITE MYSELF
IN LIKE QUENTIN TARANTINO
WOULD DO.
I WROTE A SCREEN PLAY AND I
COULDN'T GET ANYBODY TO LOOK
AT IT.
I DIDN'T WANT TO GIVE UP SO I
HAD AN IDEA MAYBE IT'S EASIER
TO TURN IT IN A NOVEL TO GET
IT PUBLISHED THAT WAY.
IN 2012 I TURNED IT INTO A
NOVEL AND TOOK A FEW YEARS AND
I GOT IT OUT THIS WAY AND
BRAND SPANKING NEW NOVEL.
"BLOOD IN THE STREETS."
>> Tucker: AMAZING.
SET WHERE?
>> NEW HAVEN, CONNECTICUT,
WHERE I WAS BORN AND RAISED IN
THE 1970s.
HOMAGE TO THE '70s GRITTY
COP FILMS.
FICTION BUT HISTORICAL CONTEXT
IN NEW HAVEN IN THE 1970s.
>> Tucker: INTERESTING.
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE BOOKS
THAT HAS ONLY BEEN READ INSIDE
FOX NEWS.
I KEEP GETTING TEXT AND
E-MAILS.
HAVE YOU READ THE BOOK?
IT'S GREAT!
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: PEOPLE OUTSIDE
THE CHANNEL READ IT.
WHAT IS THE REACTION?
>> PEOPLE CLOSE TO ME HAVE AND
THEY MESSAGE ME THEY LIKE IT.
MAYBE THEY ARE JUST BEING
NICE.
IT'S SO WEIRD BECAUSE I HAVE
BEEN WITH THE MATERIAL SO LONG
IN MY HEAD THAT IT'S NOW
SURREAL.
I NEVER ENVISIONED IT GETTING
OUT THERE AND PEOPLE WILL HAVE
A REACTION TO IT AND COME UP
AND ASK OR QUESTION ME ABOUT
IT.
SO IT'S KIND OF, YOU KNOW,
IT'S ALMOST -- I'M TAKEN ABACK
THAT PEOPLE ARE